صباح دام على مدينه رفح جنوب قطاع غزه
بفعل سلسله من الغارات الجويه الاسريه
التي طالت منازل سكنيه في منطقه تل
السلطان ومنطقه حي الزهور غربي وشمالي
مدينه رفح ادى ذلك الى ارتقاء على الاقل
11 فلسطينيا جلهم من المدنيين بفعل هذه
الغارات التي طالت هذه المنازل في ليله
تعد اصعب ربما منذ اسابيع على مدينه رفح
واكثر من ذلك من حيث حجم وحده الغارات
الجويه كما تشاهدون هنا امامكم هذه
المشاهد لحجم الدمار في هذه الشقق السكنيه
وهذه البنايه التي قصفت من قبل الطيران
الحربي
الاسرائيلي وكان بداخلها عدد من المدنيين
العزل ما بين اطفال ونساء البعض منهم
شهداء البعض منهم اصيبوا جراء هذا القصف
كذلك هنا كما نشاهد منازل مجاوره لحق بها
الضرر
والدمار بفعل هذا
القصف انا يا سيدي محمد حسين محمد المغيري
احنا من غزه منطقه الشيخ رضوان منطقه
النصر وجينا على منطقه هي الزهور
مصبح وتم استهداف البيت اللي احنا قاعدين
فيه يعني الحمد لله رب العالمين شهيده وام
المراه وام وبنتها والباقي اصابات الحمد
لله انا اصابات في الراس وزوجتي برضه نفس
الحاجه والحمد لله فضل الله ما شاء فعل لا
عمرنا توقعنا يصير معنا شي مواطنين
مسالمين ما نا علاقه في اي حاجه يتم
استهداف الابرياء والاطفال وه وهذه قه
الحرب الصهيونيه غير هيك ايش بدهم يسوي
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل ربنا سطرنا والحمد
لله رب العالمين هذا كله هي ادعاءات كاسب
ما فيش منطقه في من السلك للسلك امنه كل
المناطق مستهدفه وهدول جماعه كذابين واللي
صدقوهم كذابين زيهم تثير هذه الغارات
مخاوف السكان هنا من ان تكون مقدمه لتوسع
العمليه البريه الاسرائيليه لتطال هذه
المدينه التي لا طالما كانت ماوا لمئات
الاف النازحين من مختلف مناطق قطاع غزه
الشاعر الجزيره مدينه رفح